[Music]
on today's show we talked to a brand new
dad who's struggling with the little
baby girl who won't sleep
we talked to a young man who's trying to
love his mom who's an alcoholic
and we talk to a wife who lives in a
home where the gas lights
burn brightly stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john dolone show
the show where we talk about your mental
health your relationships your life
the good stuff the tough stuff all of it
man we're so glad you joined us there's
literally
750 trillion podcasts
from some dude in his basement talking
about his favorite kind of toads
to i don't know real podcast and then
there's this one
and i'm so grateful that you joined us
rumor has it we are up to
39 listeners and so surely we don't have
all of you on right now so i'm
i'm guessing we've got about 12 of you
now out of the total 39.
that's you know about 33 i'm good with
that so hey we're glad that you're here
tell your friends and if this is like a
guilty pleasure and you don't want to
tell your friends super understand that
too
but listen if you want to be on the show
talk ah
i said listen kelly five bucks in the
jar
for those of you that's a little inside
baseball
one of the most annoying things in the
world is when you're listening to
something
somebody talking to you or you're
listening to a podcast
and they say hey listen your response
should be i am idiot
i am listening so i've decided i'm gonna
say give kelly five bucks
um she's drastic dramatically overpaid
for what she does but who doesn't need
another five bucks
here and there um when i said listen so
back it up i would love for you if you
want to be on the show
you want to talk about mental health
your relationships um i don't charge
anything
and the advice is worth about what you
pay for it but i'd love to have you on
the show
if you want to be on give me a call
1-844-693-3291
leave a message let us know what's going
on like 1984 86 leave a detailed message
and your number at the beep or if you
want to email us
you can go to johndaloney.com ask fill
out the form
and we will get back to you
james is still gone so we got the
maestro ben hill
playing with the knobs over there and
doing a great job you're communicating
well oh thank you
um
we're gonna have to have a hard
conversation me and james when he gets
back from
helping others or whatever community
service he does kelly
you're brilliant as always
i can't hear you
i was just talking about how good ben
was doing and i guess he didn't plug you
in
[Applause]
looks like james still has a job that
was actually totally my fault
man talk about moving up to the big
leagues and striking check it out
yeah sorry ben just kidding but actually
i have a question
okay what's your question so just so
everybody listening anytime kelly says i
have a question
usually it's why is it hard for you to
get to work on time
why are you an idiot wow so this is an
actual question that i need you to
your knowledge okay so i've heard you
talk about ruminating
before yes and i'm a ruminator
from way back love to replay
conversations
or how conversations i think i should
have imaginary ones where you always win
oh where i win them all by the way all
of them and i'm
amazing and sharp and witty and i just
crush the other person
yes but i've had one before
where that actually played out oh you
got to actually have the conversation
yeah and it it was devastating not
because i won
yes but because it just didn't go like i
planned and i
said all the things that i wanted to say
yes and there was some collateral damage
and it was
one of the worst things it's this
horrible memory in my head but
i didn't even know what that was called
until i've heard you say ruminating so
can you expound on that because
you talk about it sometimes and you use
the word and i think there's probably a
lot of us out there that do it
so can you talk about that and explain
it yes let me ask you one more question
are you a catastrophizer
meaning do you like to do you see the
worst case
scenarios with your kids or your husband
or your situation or your work
because i'm very much a realist okay you
know very to the point enneagram i know
you don't believe in it but eight
that kind of just this is just it just
do it for those of y'all i don't know
what the enneagram is if you just um
pick some glitter and throw it in the
air and be like ah it's kind of like
that
okay so you're an eight right which
means you've designated yourself as a
hard charger
um i'm a challenger i challenge things
and
my husband uses the term bulldozer
man he is delicate with his with his
work
we all look cute we all love a delicate
husband okay so
ruminating is um it's when those
thoughts like lightning bolts pop into
your head and then they
the way i look at it is um seeds fall on
a field right and ruminating is when i
make the decision and i am pretty
intentional about that language when i
choose
to water those seeds fertilize those
seeds and just spend a lot of time
dwelling in those my my my ruminating is
was often especially when i was younger
it was about fights
i would have these imaginary physical
confrontations with people
and they would always play out in a way
where i was
incredibly victorious and then
i joined an mma gym and learned how to
fight
and realized oh that would have not gone
that way at all it would have ended
terribly for me
um but also i'm a bad ruminator i tend
to be a catastrophizer
um you know recently you know the gulf
of mexico south of where i grew up was
on fire
right i look at that and then it's 110
degrees in portland and
all of a sudden i'm wondering what my
grandkids are going to eat now they're
going to do this you know
and here's the cover and then i go back
to the here's the conversations i'm
gonna have right now
and they're gonna go like this and then
the senator's gonna say i don't
i you can't handle the truth and i'm
gonna be like i get it right and then
none of that goes that way so ruminating
is when those thoughts
lightning bolt into your head and you
give them an audience
and then you stir that pot sometimes
some of us
um stir that pot with a wooden spoon
sometimes we
um push put it in a blender and we hit a
button
so kelly for me it's understanding what
you just said
very few people get an opportunity to
live one out
and it feels like i'm gonna win this
this conversation it's gonna feel so
good i'm gonna do this and this
and then you have it and there's
collateral damage somebody's listening
kids are involved you hurt somebody and
you think that's gonna feel good it
doesn't
ruminating is a waste of time and here's
where i think we get addicted to it is
it feels like productive worrying
it feels like we are protecting
ourselves and worrying it feels like i'm
gonna have my conversation with the boss
and i'm gonna
get this raised and i'm gonna let them
know that they've been it always feels
like it's gonna feel good and it doesn't
here's a good example i testified in a
court case once it was a heartbreaking
situation
the guy got a long um prison sentence it
was heartbreaking for everybody
i liked this guy he was a funny guy but
he also did some some pretty gnarly
stuff
um i testified in the case and
i thought that i would feel good when
justice was served and i remember the
next morning
when the sentence was read i got
it was queasy i felt gross and i called
a mentor of mine who did a lot of
testifying and i asked her
hey i just feel like he got sentenced to
jail
and there's some justice for the victim
and she said nobody wins
nobody wins in these situations right so
when you have the big justice
conversation and
i'm gonna tell him this or i'm gonna
fist fight that or i'm going to
nobody wins when you ruminate um sitting
in your bed and catastrophizing thinking
the worst case in the worst case in the
worst case in the worst case
just magical fantasies man it's as much
a fantasy
as uh unicorns are going to land and i'm
going to get the guy and he's going to
complete me or we're going to have a
family of four and suddenly we're all
going to feel better
it's just not real it's not true it's a
fantasy
and so catastrophizing um ruminating
it's a waste of time so what i do
i've got two strategies that i use
because i do it a lot i start to do it a
lot i don't do much anymore
number one is i literally say the word
out lied out loud nope
stop and i will say those words to
myself my wife will just roll her eyes
and laugh because i'll be walking
through the living room and i'll just
say no
and she'll look and go all right
deloney's talking to himself again
um but i'll just say stop and when it
gets
where it's starting to spin on me i will
literally write down these thoughts one
at a time
and you've heard me say this but then
i'll just go line by line and demand
evidence from them
usually it feels like there's a hundred
things in my head and usually it's about
six
or it's about nine and i'll write them
down three of them may be true
one of them i can do a thing about the
other two i can't and then the rest of
it's usually garbage it's not true at
all
i don't have any data to support my
thoughts or feelings or anything on it
so
um that's what i do with ruminating hope
that helps um
thanks for the call kelly appreciate
that you're very welcome
thank you and i don't think you're a
bulldozer i
i think you probably do but that's okay
i've learned to accept that
i just choose we get things done you're
such a bulldozer all right let's go to
james
in indianapolis what's up brother james
how are we doing man
not bad how are you doing doctor we are
making it work dude making it work
doing all right so what's up how's it
going
yeah well um i'm not sleeping well
because
uh about 15 days ago not about 15 days
exactly 15 days ago
uh my wife gave birth to our beautiful
daughter
all right man congratulations dude 15.
15 days ago so you're is this your first
one
yep it is our first one congrats man so
why aren't you sleeping um
well you like what i did there i know
why you're not sleeping
you have another human in your house
that just poops and screams all day long
all the time
[Laughter]
oh man that was such a dead exhale okay
so but in all seriousness tell me what's
going on man
yeah so it actually has to do with
sleeping um so in the middle of night
you know i'm with my kid
um and and my question is how do i
really maintain that connection with my
daughter when i'm
frequently frustrated and sometimes
angry with her just because
she's yelling and screaming for
no apparent reason yeah um
a couple of things we'll back out of
that what is what's your
arrangement right now here's what i mean
by arrangement
um i've heard i don't know anybody
specifically but i've heard some folks
that were
have a arrangement with their wife or
husband
if i'm up feeding the baby you're up to
right
and my wife her philosophy and
and most of the women i know my wife's
philosophy was
i'm gonna be up one of us has to be
sleeping
one of us has to be clear-headed
throughout the day um it's ridiculous
for you to get up and then
after a couple of weeks they developed a
really
unique um relationship
that she didn't want me getting involved
with right so she did me a
sleep-deprived sleep starved
um once she was able to pump and all
that stuff then i could get up in the
middle of the night and
feed and change diapers and stuff like
that um but you know then
she had to get a pump into it so this is
a whole thing but have what's y'all's
arrangement
yeah so um right now we're breastfeeding
or
my wife's breastfeeding there you go i'm
very bad at that
we're not doing anything she is but
okay um so usually what happens is
um i'll wake up when the kid's screaming
um
and you know or just unhappy during
unhappy
i'll take care of her but it's time to
eat and i give her over to mom
uh i go to sleep for you know the
15 or 45 minutes however long it is you
know and hopefully when the kids then
uh eating we put her back in the crib
and it's all good but sometimes you know
then i'm back awake
yeah uh looking at the kid and you know
my wife
um with c-section so i'm trying to give
her as much sleep as possible so she can
actually
heal and cover yeah and not be you know
down and out for the next 17 weeks yeah
yeah
so um first man thanks for being
involved dad
thanks for being a husband who's
thinking big picture about his wife
um sometimes i take a lot of calls from
dads that aren't so i appreciate you
being an involved guy
um so there is the c-section like you
hear about it so much that
you forget that it's like somebody gets
cut open and they take their guts out
and then take a human out and then put
guns i mean it's a major surgery right
and we don't often think that we just
like oh i just had a c-section sweet
cool
not sweet and cool it's a big deal it's
common but it's a big deal
so yes there's a there is a necessary
manual
in it and here's the thing take the baby
out you would be waking up in the middle
of the night
if your wife had a major surgery like
this anyway that's who you are
right um and then you toss
a kid in there that yeah you're looking
at two in the morning your brain's not
fully on and it's not fully off and you
just
got this being who has took taking your
wife away from you
she's taking your money away from you
you're exhausted and she just won't stop
screaming
right yeah so go ahead
that's right and and you know the
really the feeling i had but six days
ago was really it was a
i participate you know one main event
but it happens a lot but it's like
i instantly switch from you know this is
my daughter this is my this is another
human too
this is a machine yeah that is broken
yep
and i myself we say you know we want to
i grew up in the south um you know i
want to give her something to cry about
yeah yeah and and obviously i'm not
at all going to do any of that right
instantly in my brain that's happened
yeah so number one dude you're exhausted
give yourself some grace okay
parents um and we don't this doesn't get
talked about a lot
um postpartum and women is talked about
a lot and intrusive thoughts and angry
thoughts and violent thoughts
there's a lot of literature and
discussion on that it's not with guys
okay and so i want you to know being
raged out
at two in the morning after on week two
and your wife can't move and this little
baby is screaming her head off
um you're not crazy okay
you will not under any circumstances
ever hit this kid
got it yes are we in agreement on that
oh yes 100 you'll put the baby down and
you'll walk outside and take a walk down
the street if you get to that place okay
yeah um i don't think that's going to
happen i don't want you to
spook yourself or freak yourself out
just because you're
you're at the end of your psychological
capacity right now and you're fried
okay um i think it's an important moment
to have a couple of conversations one
with your wife
one about just about sleep about
catching up about this looks like
the second thing is man do you have
somebody that can come stay with you for
a night just let you get
caught up a little bit like a friend or
a parent or a grandparent who would just
say hey i need a night
um we have a couple of friends in the
area we just um
moved about a year ago okay we're still
trying to get those relationships
but um here's what would be a gift and
it may be a buddy
it may be one of your guy friends it may
be one of your wife's friends
um it may be a moment when you call
somebody and hey
people want to help they often don't
know how they don't
you know they don't know how but if you
ask hey i've got to i'm fried i got to
get some sleep one night
um could you come over and when the baby
gets up here's what we need you to do
and he said help
it will help you reach out for help what
you're going to need to do over the
course of this kid's life and it would
give somebody else something to do
that may be an option here um here's
another big thing dude
anger just points you towards something
you care about
okay and everything in your life is
different now
and at some point y'all are gonna have
to sit down and have a fun
dreaming adventure about what was how
long were y'all married before you get
where you had this kid
uh three years okay almost four years
almost four years
so let's just be a realist about it how
long did y'all date before that
um three years okay so
half a decade the better part of right
six years y'all
had butterflies you made out and hooked
up whenever you want to y'all just
randomly went to movies on wednesday
nights you went to concerts together
and everything was
cool and messy and you could be angry at
each other
and then fix it whatever right and now
everything is new and the challenge is
your anger often comes from i remember
what was and i just need to get back to
that
and so there's a part of what y'all are
experiencing right now that
that's not coming back you have a new
cool thing and you have to be
intentional and honest and open about
what this new cool thing is going to be
and it's going to happen one way or the
other so
architect and engineer it right draw it
up tell you what's going to look like
here it's going to be this new cool
thing
those days are over but we're still
going to be able to make out whenever we
want to we may have to just put on a
calendar sometimes
or we're still going to be able to x and
y and z go to a movie on a weekday but
we're going to call somebody this time
all that stuff will change and shift and
it's not any less than it's just
different
you just have to be intentional so all
of a sudden you're not living in this
past right
and bro listen you're two weeks in
everything feels crazy right now i
promise
promise it'll settle back okay
did you ever play sports in college in
high school or college oh i did cross
country
oh my gosh perfect okay so where
wha wha did you all run about three and
a half miles on a normal race
um we did 4.8 4.8 yeah
okay you got bunched up and everybody
went out too fast
and you're at mile one and a half and
you are
looking down at your watch and you
realize that you are out way too fast
and you can't slow down that's where
you're at right now okay
you don't stop the race you don't just
quit you don't go
but you are exhausted and you realize oh
man we got a long way to go
okay that's where you're at this season
that you're in right now i promise you
promise you promise you will end
okay i promise it'll be a few months
but it will end so i want you to do two
things for me number one
i want you to tell me you're two weeks
in what's something you miss about the
old days
already and be honest there's a
bajillion men out there listening and
they'll know if you're lying
yeah i i honestly i just miss the the
ability just to sit down and cuddle with
my wife
you know it's hard when you have a a kid
you sit down on the couch and it's like
oh she's awake let me go change the
diaper
yeah i promise
promise promise that will come back okay
i promise what's something that you are
really excited about
i'm really excited to be able to
really pour into into nikki and to my
daughter and
be able to raise her in a you know in a
way that she can make
a impact in the world
you know the best way to do that
just let her know that she's loved and
some of the best ways you can let
somebody know don't ever let that little
girl go to bed without you looking her
in the eye let her know that you love
her
saying the words and
bro
so sometimes the the most important ways
to show somebody love them is the teeny
tiny little things
it's the diaper when you're so tired you
can't even move your fingers and when
your baby's screaming
and screaming you just keep holding her
and you just keep
holding her and you just keep holding
her or you put her down or you hand it
to your wife or you do something right
but you keep showing up and you keep
showing up and you keep showing up
if you feel raged out to where you're
gonna hurt somebody
you're gonna hit somebody you're gonna
punch a hole through the sheet walk i
want you to put the baby down and walk
outside and go call somebody
asap okay um
you don't get those moments back okay
i don't think that's you i think you're
exhausted you're cooked
you miss holding your wife you want her
to be okay you want her to be able to
walk around
you want to be able to go to bed at
night and sleep all those things are
real when you're holding
a baby that's two weeks old it's all
real okay you're not broken you're not
crazy
hang in there hang in there hang in
there two things that we talked about
earlier just to wrap
up make sure you call somebody
and ask hey can one of y'all come over
once a week and just give us a break
um and that may be you maybe have to
pony up some money and fly your mom out
or
your dad out my dad comes up sometimes
and hangs out with our kids when me and
my wife are traveling it's aw he's
awesome
um in-laws coming whatever that looks
like um and it may be one of your new
friends
and the second thing is i want you
brother i want you to get with
a guy or two who has kids and have
somebody that you can text a lifeline
for me
was that i ended up having kids
later than my buddies so i had people i
could text and say am i crazy and they'd
say nah man that's just normal you're
good
and there was something norming about
having friends in my life that were
already down the road from me
they there was a couple times they said
yeah that's not super normal you should
probably call somebody that doesn't look
right or
that's just a rash or what you know i
had i had a friend holly she came over
like
when i had my first kid like what is
this is this
is this the end and she's like no it's a
rash dude you just do this and i didn't
know these things
right and so they were helpful my buddy
stephen came over
they're awesome um they live two houses
down from us but have
a couple of guys in your life that you
can call and um
let you know whether things need to be
checked up on further or and this is
just part of it brother
you're a good man hang in there you're
not broken
hang in there
i kelly ben i like talking to people who
love their kids
even though they don't know how to do it
and they don't know what they're doing i
love it love it love it love it hey
we'll take a quick break we'll be right
back on the dr john dolone show
hey what's up i want to take a quick
break to talk about the most important
question i'm asked almost every day
how do i find a counselor if you can't
find a counselor in your area
or you can't afford one i've got a
solution for you
i've partnered with a better help for
customized
online therapy video chat text chat
phone counseling it's a licensed
therapist whenever and wherever
you need them go to betterhelp.com
for 10 off your first month it's cheaper
and it's available
all the time this is for you your family
and for everyone else that's coming your
way
take care of your mental health go to
betterhelp.com
hey what's up all right let's go to
brandon in columbus
ohio what's up brandon hey dr john how
are you doing
i'm good brother how are you i am doing
really well today
excellent man so what's up man how can i
help
uh yeah so i uh will
do a lot of moving pieces so i'll try to
keep this laser focused but
make sure you talk into your phone okay
can you hear me again
yeah um so grew up my mom was a
pretty intense alcoholic and um
she recently about seven or eight years
ago um
got sober thankfully and uh was doing
really well
and then just this year has kind of
relapsed and
um some added medication addictions
and just some pretty crappy stuff
and then has been in and out of the
hospital a bunch
since january and there's a couple like
serotonin overdoses
and um certain stuff like that
she's kind of had some suicidal language
in there
um and she's been a week in a
psychiatric hospital
um she's struggling huh yeah just
struggling so i'm just
i'm i'm like wondering um you know
half half what's my responsibility half
uh
like i just don't know what to do i feel
like she has no will
um and you know it's just just tough so
anything what's your relationship like
with her
not good yeah um it was
it wasn't good growing up uh well it was
awesome growing up until i
became the age where i was like oh not
everyone's mom
drinks this much so um and then
it got really bad and then she got sober
and we kind of reconciled and it got
better but
um the last few years hasn't been that
good at all
yeah dude i'm sorry man
that's all right thanks man how old are
you
i am 25.
man so you know this i'm just gonna say
it out loud
um there's not a lot of givens
in the world um not a lot of
should always bees but every little boy
you got brothers and sisters i have one
little
down syndrome brother okay
yeah that's even a whole other
complication but
every little boy one of the givens of
the universe should be
that you can count on your mom and that
you can count on your dad
and they didn't show up man i'm sorry
do you have a dad in the picture at all
i do
they've uh they've been divorced for
since i was in like seventh grade
um and he's he's in the picture he
you know cares for my my brother you
know here and there and
um you know he wants the same for my mom
as well even though they're
apart so yeah so it sounds like your
mom's got a lot of
baggage and trauma of her own she's
still wrestling with huh
yeah yeah for sure okay yeah i uh
i feel like i've tried to have that
conversation with her and
you know um intense psychotherapy and
yeah i don't know it just doesn't land
so there's not my experience has been
there's not a lot of conversation to be
had with addicts
um there is a lot of connection to be
had but there's not a lot of
oh okay does that make sense it's not
like they're missing a piece of
information
most of the true addicts like you're
talking about your mom who've been at it
a long long time
they they know more than anybody
how awful this is they know more than
anybody
how badly they want to quit um
they know what this like you're losing
your family they know
right i don't know a lot of i know a few
but i don't know a lot of addicts that
can't see it
right um and so that makes those
conversations that makes those
learning opportunities hard um
here's the best thing a couple things i
can give you it sounds like your mom has
crossed a new line
where now she's using pills and it's
almost as though she's practicing an
exit strategy
which often for addicts who've been at a
long time they just get exhausted and i
don't know that they want to kill
themselves as much as they want this
thing to stop
right and so suicide often isn't the
problem suicide becomes the solution
to an exhausted frustrating just getting
hounded and hounded by these ghosts of
addiction right
what ultimately did she say
made her contemplate suicide ended up in
a psych ward
yeah she was um
i was at work one day and around
lunchtime
she just i answered the phone and i
could immediately tell that she was
you know drunk and on other stuff
and just was like you know um
i don't think i can do this anymore you
know uh
your brother loves you you need to take
care of them
um all that stuff you know so she that
that's that's when those conversations
they don't scare me like in a like
horror movie kind of way but
that's somebody who's not just playing
around right
sure that's somebody who's thinking it
through and they're making arrangements
and they're making a plan right um so
since she's been out has she been clean
since she's been out of the psych ward
or she just go right back
she hasn't she it's nowhere near the way
she used to be but it's been like
er you know i i might talk to her once a
week and
um from what i hear it seems like she's
maybe a couple weeks or a couple days of
the week she's
you know under something um i don't i'm
not sure it's every day but
definitely back at it since she's been
out yeah okay y'all live in the same
town
uh we live about 30 minutes apart okay
and then real quick tell me
what the situation is with your little
brother do you have custody of him or
does your dad have custody of him what's
the situation with him
yeah so he my mom actually lives with
her sister
my aunt who's just spent her whole life
taking care of other people
and cares for my brother and along with
my dad
okay so sounds like a pretty
remarkable woman there huh oh yeah
incredible so there's a couple of
short-term and long-term things okay are
you a reader
i do i enjoy reading okay there's two
books i want you to read number one
is a book called in the realm of hungry
ghosts
and we'll link to it in the show notes
it's by gabor mate
it's a it's a new book on
it's not new but um it's one of the most
revelation revolutionary books on
addiction i've ever read
it's hard to read um but it is
remarkable the second book is a book i
read this
year that was just astounding and it's
called the unbroken brain
a revolutionary way of understanding
addiction
um and i'll mispronounce the author's
name but it's
my a m-i-a-i
s-z-a-l-a-v-i-t-z and again we'll link
to that in the show notes as well
um it really reframes addiction it
actually walks through the history of
addiction how why
how and why we started calling it a
disease um and the medicalization of it
and she reframes it as a learning
disorder
as a way a body learns to cope over time
and when we think learning disorder you
think oh just stop or
it's not that easy um it's still super
complex but here's what's beautiful
um we solve diseases by isolating
the disease into a into an isolated room
and we give it medicine and we give it a
plan and by looking at it as
a learning dis as a learning disorder
really
it you reframe learning disorders
through active intense connection
right so here's the deal beating up an
addict isn't helpful
right think of addiction as a connection
disorder
it's somebody desperately trying to
connect and they can't for whatever
reason they're traumatized as a kid and
learn that relationships will will
abuse you get you hurt get you killed
then
relationships aren't safe and at the
same time a body has to have
relationships
and pills and alcohol can help sometimes
so beating up somebody yelling at them
trying to give them new information
sending them books that's
i've just never seen that be successful
an addict has to decide i'm done with
this and then they have to go get
with part of a group whether that's a a
whether that's a church whatever that
looks like
they have to get with a group of people
and learn how
to have relationship again learn how to
have safe vulnerable interactions again
that's why so many people find aaa
successful they get to practice
relationships together
practice vulnerability together that you
can't do when
other relationships are going to get you
hurt um some people don't like aaa
i just i think the idea of it is
remarkable so here's the things you can
do okay number one
is firm compassion i love you
but here's my boundaries right so she
can't show up at your house if she's
been drinking
if she calls you and she's super drunk
say hey mom i love you
um i told you i i i can't talk to you
when you're super drunk or you're super
high i love talking to you though
so tomorrow i'd love to get together and
talk to you okay so give me a call back
and gently hang up the phone right this
is you
compassionate and boundaries okay
the second thing is is getting on the
same page with everybody
when's the last time you went and had
just lunch or breakfast with um
your mom's sister the one who's taking
care of her your dad your little brother
have you ever just gone out and talked
to her i haven't
okay so you're 25 now and so i would
tell you
stop looking at this as a little boy as
a teenager start looking at this as
at some point you're going to be
responsible for your mom's extended care
at some point you're gonna be
responsible for your little brother
um and so i'm gonna start leveling up
and what leveling up means is i'm gonna
take
go out to lunch i'm gonna pay and i'm
gonna take her out to lunch and
first and foremost say thank you so much
for taking care of my family
you're a saint you are a model for me as
a young man
i want to learn how and why tell me my
mom's history
tell me my dad's history tell me like
what makes my little brother tick
and just listen and learn from her she
sounds like a brilliant wise
compassionate woman
and this is also going to put everybody
on the same page
probably do the same thing with your dad
and start
asking him questions does he have a
special needs trust for
your brother does he have a will some of
those these are just 25 year old
man-to-man conversations now
okay yeah um and what you're doing is
you're getting everybody on the same
page
and everybody and you can let everybody
know hey here's my boundaries with mom
she calls me and she's drunk she calls
me she's hot i'm just going to tell her
i love her but i'm not going to talk to
her when she's this way i'ma hang up
if she shows up my house is drunk she's
not going to be welcome inside my house
because my wife's here my kids my kids
are here etc or whatever that's going to
look like for you
and then here's the number four constant
constant reaching out whether that's
text messages
i love you know i if you listen to the
show at all i love the handwritten
letter
every week i'm going to sit down this is
for you this is for you but ends up
being for her
every week you take 30 minutes to an
hour and write her a letter it could be
one page two page on
notebook paper with the lines on it um
and let her know how your week was let
her know that you miss her
hope she's doing great but these letters
over time
it will slowly and i'm talking like a
drip like trying to fill up a swimming
pool with a tiny little drip
it's gonna slowly reconnect with her
it's gonna give her a part of her
heart and her mind this relationship's
safe this relationship's safe
it could also spiral her into shame and
all that that's her situation not yours
but i want you to have a i want you to
look up in five years
and what's that what's five times 50 i
wanted her holding 250 letters from her
son
did you say pretty much some variation
of this week was a hard week this was a
good week i met a girl
my wife marriage is doing good whatever
your life situation is we're having a
baby
and i want you to know i love you and i
hope you're doing well right
if you can set up once a week or once
every two weeks hey we're gonna meet for
breakfast at cracker barrel
at nine o'clock i'm paying here's the
thing sometimes she's gonna show up
drunk
sometimes she's not gonna show up at all
and it's gonna hurt over and over again
but part of this is you healing too and
all you can heal is you and you heal
through connection so i'm gonna keep
reaching out i'm gonna keep reaching out
i'm gonna keep reaching out okay
don't take it personal when she doesn't
show up don't take it like oh my mom
hates me
she doesn't she's just not well right
she's really struggling
um and then just know this i've done
this man
not with my mom but i've i've had
relationships with addicts
it's just heartbreaking and so you got
to take care of yourself making sure
you're eating well making sure you're
taking care of stuff
there's a part of your body and brain
and heart
that is going to need connection too
dude because your mom wasn't there for
you
for a long long time right
can i ask you this do you have what are
your addictive
mechanisms what are your numbing
behaviors
that's a good question um you've got
them what are they
definitely there's um i've learned this
especially this year about myself is my
wife is uh the first one to point it out
which is awesome
and not awesome at the same time i was
just about to say
awesome not awesome yeah
um yeah i i am the ten
i'm man flee from conflict
yep um he's like my middle name and so
okay what that looks like is just like
any hard thing i'm just how can i
put every single little thing into my
schedule yeah so that i don't have
a single second to think about a hard
thing
there you go um and your schedule can
become an addiction because
it's your heart and mind and brain's way
of trying to control everything because
you lived in chaos
right and here's the thing
it will move from your schedule
to something else to something else and
it will just expand on you
and so learning how to do relational
conflict now
relational conflict in the past got you
hurt right i got you beat up i got you
set on fire i got you
your mom took off on you or whatever
that's a
cornerstone it's like air you got to
learn how to do conflict for your
marriage for your kids
and so i man i can't recommend enough
that you go see somebody go see them
with your wife
right and she sounds like an awesome
awesome woman awesome partner for you
go see somebody um and tell let them
know i grew up in the home of an
alcoholic i grew up in a home of
with divorce i grew up with a special
needs little brother um
i got a lot to unpack and i got some
skills i need to learn i need to learn
conflict i need to learn what love looks
like because i didn't see it growing up
i need to learn how to practice how to
have hard conversations because i got a
lot of those ahead of me
um and then you and your wife are gonna
have to just understand probably we're
gonna be taking care of my little
brother
and have him around a lot have him a
part of the life of your life
whatever that looks like for y'all but
yeah you're at that 25 h
and that's when things get hard so i've
given you a lot here i'm not going to
recap at all brother
i want you to know this i'm grateful for
your heart man
it's a heartbreaking call when a when a
son calls me and says man how do i love
my mom and when my mom doesn't even love
herself
it's hard and it's got to keep showing
up and got to keep showing up
listen to this episode do it listen to
it with your wife
y'all come up with a game plan on what
this is going to look like for y'all
what boundaries and compassionate
boundaries are going to look like
what firm boundaries can look like take
the folks out to dinner that you need to
take them out
get get your will get special needs
stuff taken care of
and you're in it for a long haul brother
but i wanted you to know there's healing
and laughter and joy on the other end of
this deal
and i'm proud of you for being willing
to do the work you're awesome man
all right let's take one more quick call
let's go to hannah in fort wayne hannah
what's going on
hi how are you good how are you
i'm pretty good i'm good
oh pretty good you're not so what's up
um yeah so i'm 33 years old um
i never necessarily thought i had an
anger issue
um it never was visible in my childhood
or
anything like that um i think of myself
as a pretty easy going person
but your life is telling you that you
have an anger issue
well i mean me when i i mean it's very
evident that i do but
it has to do with my marriage um so
you know it's it has to do with when i
make a mistake which in marriage you do
um you know whoa whoa i do not ever
ever make another oh that's nice i'm
totally kidding i made like seven this
morning
okay so yeah whenever you make a mistake
then what
um so then you know i'll apologize for
it and say yeah
you know i did that um he'll he'll ask
me
you know why did you do that and i'll
kind of explain
or something and then he'll say well
you're making excuses
um and then i'm not making excuses i'm
trying to
to not you know do it again i'm trying
to just
you know talk through it and um and then
you know he'll say you just need to just
literally when i make a mistake
they just i don't know i guess he
doesn't want me to ever talk about
anything of why and just own up to it
but you know i did apologize um but then
what are these mistakes hannah like is
it like he keeps coming home and his
best friend is
it in your bedroom is it this mistake or
is it like
i didn't take the trash out no um i mean
it started early
on um like if i say things uh in front
of his friends or family
um that you know upsets him or
embarrasses him even if it's like you
know
jordan doesn't like to eat vegetables um
you know that he doesn't like if i say
that necessarily
um so and i to i'm a very blunt honest
that's a struggle for me i mean i i'm
just making conversation i might
i mean and i do say something i
shouldn't say and i understand that
at the same time i can't guarantee i'll
never do that again
so one of the cornerstones of somebody
who is
in a relationship with somebody who is
emotionally immature
is they for instance
are sitting somewhere and somebody
brings up vegetables and you say
oh he's not gonna eat that and then
suddenly he gets his feelings
like that is becomes a death blow to a
soul
right and then at home it becomes a
whole thing
how dare you put me on blast in front of
my friends and family
and you're like dude i'm sorry i forgot
about the don't thing about vegetables
thing
like i don't want to hear it you just
don't even you i don't you're just
making excuses
right what happens in short order
is you start feeling crazy
and this is and use this this is
like the gas lights burn brightly in
hannah's home in fort wayne indiana
okay and you start feeling crazy
and then all of a sudden you start
trying to filter everything that you say
and every joke you tell and every like
okay is this oak is this okay
and that bar moves
because when somebody who's when a great
gaslighter gets a hold of somebody they
start
that finish line there's never a moment
when it would
then it will be you didn't look at me
enough or you kept looking at that
guy or why are you talking to my mom
more than me
and you're like okay i'll solve for that
problem and then pretty soon you're just
sitting at home
not doing anything right and you feel
insane
and then you get raged out right and so
insanity i often like to describe as
like being in a
like my shoulders are clenched right now
your whole situation is making me crazy
and i'll get crazy on this show this is
one that makes me my skin crawl
um it's like being in a pet kennel and
then eventually you just rage like you
just start rattling the
the ken the the cage and then the person
who's gaslighting you goes c c and then
you go
oh i just did that i've never done that
what's happening i must be
crazy and it just all reinforces itself
in this weird nutty dance
does that make sense yeah that sounds
exactly right
oh god i can't stand this okay
how long have you been married to this
guy
about nine and a half years okay has
this been going on forever or is it
slowly just moving and moving and moving
and moving
no it started early on okay yeah right
away
okay so here's i'm going to tell you
two things this uh this ends one of
three ways not two ways one of three
ways
number one it ends with
tragically some separation of some sort
and you are completely nutty you are
cooked
and he is self-righteous indignant and
justified and it ends with somebody
having an affair or somebody just
imploding
okay it's something just blows up right
because here's what happens
and you can tell me if i'm right or
wrong you stop
you start keeping secrets you stop
telling him about things that happened
at work you stop
telling him about a way you feel about
something
and then eventually you will find
someone else to talk to
yes that has happened yes and
he will whether he cognitively knows it
or not
he will feel that you stop talking to
him
and he has to connect he's a person and
he's gonna find somebody to connect to
and all of a sudden it's everybody's in
la la land and they didn't mean to get
there but that's here's where we are
right so that's step number one step
number two
everybody just slowly drowns and you
wake up and you've been married for 20
years and you're roommates
you don't like him he doesn't like you
your kids are just whatever and you go
to baseball games and sit by each other
usually with a kid in the middle
right and it's just a slow suffocation
or the third is somebody
turns all the lights on stops the music
and stops this dance that's been going
on for nine years now
and says i love you too much to let you
continue to say i'm not a good person
because i talk about vegetables
you've got to grow up and deal with your
emotional immaturity
i do love you and yes i want to honor
and respect your boundaries and if you
don't want me talking about our marriage
or whatever out in public fine
also you knew who you married and i'm
loud and i'm fun and i like to be silly
and i like to make jokes and that's the
way i show love and yes i go too far and
now i'm talking to myself here by the
way hannah
and i know there's certain like there's
just certain things on this show i've
talked about and my wife has said hey
i heard from a friend um that this came
up she didn't listen to the show
and um she said hey that's iris don't
talk about that and she was right
and i wasn't trying to mean or rude or
but that was fair
um but that line is not just continuing
to move right
but somebody's got to throw a flag and
say i'm going to see a marriage
counselor i'd love for you to come with
us because i think our
marriage is in trouble and i'm telling
you right now it is in trouble
okay um you should be able to be you and
at the same time be respectful and treat
your husband with dignity
and at the same time he should be able
to be him and treat you with dignity and
respect
and this just sounds like a
it just sounds like the toilet bowl is
starting to spin faster and faster
and faster and somebody's gotta hit the
pause button am i right
yeah well and we have uh done marriage
counseling two different times
um both of
me saying we need this because i'm like
i'm a crazy person
you know i'm so like i i need help you
know and
one time um he didn't want to do it and
i was like okay well i'm just going to
go by myself i'm just going to do it you
know
and and then after a few sessions this
is my pastor's um
wife you know said we need to get him
here and
um so yeah we have done that that's my
other concern is i don't know
i feel like i'm always you know and and
to be honest i did tell him about this
call today because i
oh i just lost your hand he's still
there i want to make sure
there you go okay you know if he's not
comfortable i don't want to do it
yeah oh yeah i'm here can you hear me
yeah i got you back
in my car there's a storm okay um but uh
but yeah we've we've been down this road
before okay
um and you know i'm always the one that
says we need help
um so that that's also a concern
it is but he has no incentive to get
help because you know
he has no incentive to get help because
you
change every time and you're the crazy
one
right so there's no incentive
okay there's there's nothing in his
world that is rattling his world because
every time you rattle it
you fix it you stop doing your thing
gotcha and so number one
are you crazy
no i don't think so okay now
a lot of crazy people don't know they're
crazy hannah is it you
uh i i
i don't think so but i do get really
frustrated when i'm
when i do apologize and then and it's
like i'm expected to be perfect and i'm
like that's impossible
it is you're right you're right it gets
me i mean it is
so i i've never and i've never been
treated this way before i've never
i mean this is all so i don't think i am
but i've also never
been in this position before exactly
that's right
so um oh
man do you have a relationship with his
parents
yeah yeah we have good relationship with
both both sides okay
um i want you to read a book called
um gosh i've just lost it it's
about emotionally mature parents um
adult adult kids adult children of
emotionally immature parents i want you
to read that book
okay okay and it's a book for
adult children who are trying to figure
out why they are why they are
but and it talks about their parents but
i've also seen couples go
oh i live in this now okay i want you to
read that book
and if it hits home maybe he'll read it
too
ultimately i think you're going to need
to find a therapist that is
a relational life therapist and that's
out of the school of terence real
uh terry real you've got to find a
therapist that will take your husband on
and most marriage and family therapist
won't do that
and it's a shame but some and that will
take you on too because i know you're
not perfect in this deal
um but i also know nine years of scar
tissue becomes nine years of scar tissue
right so i guarantee if he was on the
phone
um he would be telling me another story
and his story probably makes sense too
okay and if he wants to call me i'd love
to talk to him also
um i don't want to paint him as the evil
guy here but i
yeah what you're telling me is just a
playbook and i've seen it over and over
and over again
okay and i'm just telling you it doesn't
end well
and so i want somebody whether that's
you flip on all the lights
and say i'm gonna go take care of me
because that's at the end of the day
you've already tried marriage therapy
you've got to find somebody that will
take him on
call somebody and let them know and sit
down and say i want to get well i want
to take care of me
that doesn't mean you're trying to
figure out ways that you can be perfect
that means that you are trying to figure
out ways to deal with a
heavy gas light or somebody who's
emotionally mature somebody who's
struggling on their own
that doesn't have the skill set to be in
a marriage right now
that doesn't know how to communicate
well right
and here's the other thing hannah i've
ganged up on him a little bit
or a lot if there are things like hey i
don't want you talking about our sex
life with our friends then don't do that
right there's a balance here too um
hey i don't work out enough and i'm
embarrassed about my body don't call me
you know fatso whatever the thing is
that there is a line there right
um that make sure that you're honoring
and treating him with dignity too
um but don't be in a relationship i'm
going to tell you get divorced i'm
telling you don't be in a relationship
where
somebody is constantly making you feel
insane making you feel
crazy making you feel like you're evil
and you're sitting i don't i don't know
what's
going on here you got to go see somebody
so get that book we'll link to it in the
show notes here
and then you start seeing somebody today
call somebody today
that you haven't talked to before and
get straight to the point i live with a
with a um fire breathing gas
and i don't know what to do anymore and
i gotta learn some skills on how to
handle this
invite him if he'll come and but he's
gonna have to have a therapist that will
take him on
right thank you so so much for the call
hannah ah we'll be thinking about you i
know those are hard hard hard hard hard
and dehana's husband listening to this
dude i bet you're a good guy
in fact i almost count on it i bet
you're a good guy
and i bet that everything feels personal
and feels like you're being attacked by
a woman who loves you
and once you hear me say i don't think
she doesn't love you i think she does
love you a lot
i want you to have the courage and the
strength to say
maybe it's me maybe i'm playing a part
in this maybe
i've got a key role that i'm playing
here maybe i've got to learn some new
skills
maybe every time my feelings get hurt um
it isn't always somebody trying to go
after me or hurt me maybe i need to
learn some emotional intelligence or
some relational intelligence i need to
learn some skills
have the courage to do that man and go
open-handed don't make a therapist take
you on
go say hey i'm gonna be vulnerable here
i get
take things so personally and i know
this woman loves me oh i got some things
i gotta learn
go be brave man go be brave and uh call
me back and let me know how that goes
all right i'd love to talk to you all
right as we wrap up today's show
the song of the day the greatest song
ever written
was chosen by kelly it's a song that
makes our heart feel
full it's off the moon face record
by the one and only van morrison the
song's called end to the mystic and it
goes like this
we were born before the wind also
younger than the sun
air the bonnie boat was one as we sailed
into the mystic
you know what a bonnie boat is i don't
hark now
hear the sailors cry smell the sea and
feel the sky
let your soul and spirit fly where into
the mystic
and when that fog horn blows i'll be
coming home
and when that foghorn blows i want to
hear it i don't have to
fear it and i want to rock your gypsy
soul kelly
i want to rock your gypsy soul just like
way back in the days of old
and magnificently we will float into the
mystic
right here on the dr john dolone show